remember in February when Donald Trump
pretended to understand Japanese listen
listening to Japanese Prime Minister
Shinzo Abe a speak Japanese while Trump
stood there and nodded here's what that
looked like if you forgot heed sincerely
grateful a for will be always
heartwarming welcome according to me
five American people success I would
also like to express my sincere
gratitude to president Trump Oh Donald
you must have been very busy in this
very important at a period of a hundred
days after your inauguration yeah so
Trump only much much later realizing
that hey I don't speak Japanese and I
need to put an earpiece in to understand
what the hell this guy's saying he did
the same thing when German Chancellor
Angela Merkel came to the United States
and in this clip you're going to hear
Angela Merkel start to speak we are then
going to hear the live translation but
it takes Trump more than half a minute
to realize oh that's right I don't speak
German and I don't know what this woman
is saying and puts his earpiece in then
vo behind the stop when we speak about
trade agreements then the European Union
is negotiating those agreements for all
of the members of the European Union but
obviously there's also input by the
member states they bring to the table
what's important to them we have
underlined as an German industry gem
business community and have made the
experience that any kind of agreement
that we have concluded for example at
the very latest and with South Korea so
finally realizing I don't speak German
Trump did it again okay this time at
mar-a-lago with Chinese President Xi
Jinping and you know the video speaks
for itself no earpiece but nodding along
enthusiastically as if he now
understands Chinese say that
laziness Allah
so you will the holiness if Alchemist
people relatively novel disorder
everybody else
seemingly cares enough about what the
Chinese president is saying to have
their live translation earpieces Trump
doesn't need it he just nods along and I
should have said that Trump speaks
Mandarin I know people will write in and
say David Chinese is not a language need
to distinguish between Mandarin and
Cantonese so again no earpiece Trump
seems to have quite a prowess for Asian
languages pad that none of us knew about
you know it's funny back during the
campaign when we would point out that
Donald Trump is unqualified surrogates
would say things like well he's a good
learner he'll pick it up on the job as
if it's a job where you can just kind of
pick it up as you go while doing
apparently he's been studying these
languages German Japanese and now
Mandarin it's so amateurish I mean we're
joking about it but to let this happen
again and again so amateurish at least
pretend to care what the other diplomat
is saying but it's business as usual in
the Trump White House it would be
hilarious to have a foreign leader
insult Trump and to see Trump just
nodding along there with no earpiece and
I was thinking about this the Japanese
German and Chinese Mandarin pretending
to understand incidents let's be honest
with ourselves many times when people
are speaking to Trump in English
Trump is nodding along like he
understands he understands the words but
he doesn't really know what he's being
told right when you have national
security people briefing Trump he nods
along he seems like he understands what
they're saying but he doesn't really get
it that would be interesting if other
foreign leaders pick up on this and
perhaps they have a contentious meeting
with President Trump and they decide to
just go after him and attack him while
Trump nods along I'd like to see that oh
it would be absolutely fantastic and
Trump has made george w bush looks like
some kind of genius which is shocking
but i still talked about and i want to
say it again just because george w bush
seems reasonable compared to donald
trump
we should not normalize the george w
bush presidency Trump is more
bombastically outrageous than bush but
that doesn't mean in retrospect Bush was
a good president Trump is also sort of
pretending to know how to be President
this would have been a major story
during a normal presidency it doesn't
even register but I think it's important
Pat not to retroactively Lee see through
rose-colored glasses the presidency of
George W Bush because he seems so much
more reasonable and grounded than Trump
right especially as the george w bush
presidency fades further and further
back into history we tend to reanalyze
past administrations and it's a little
too soon to do that we often say you
need some distance from a president to
really be able to evaluate where they
rank so to speak and the more distance I
get from george w bush on policy the
lower and lower that i actually rank him
i'm on twitter at des Pakman the show is
on twitter at david pakman show follow
me there follow the show there we'll be
back after this